Thanks to the president of the
European commission or to the fondalliam
who wanted to
come to Emilia Romagna to come to
Italy to go together personally taking into
account the situation that this
region is facing and I would like The
whole nation I believe there is a
translator
stand by Italy to Real Life's  Sands Act
right now
president
I owe it precisely in the first days when
this disaster happened at the G7 but in
Japan and immediately you paid
attention to your solidarity
that the other leaders did too I
also want to thank the many
government state lakes  who have written in recent days
offering their
solidarity their willingness
to make jokes even in the face of the President
from the lion Because of
You Open
[Music]
activated the
European Civil Protection mechanism How to
thank the president Fabrizio
skunk Civil Protection have already
offered their  availability of new
member states and therefore there are already
very concrete signs of solidarity
from a European point of view The
Originals solitarity from Europe and
gone crazy by Hegel reproduction
mackenzies Activity
effectively the support of the
Union support commission can
be very important at this stage
for us
in the next  weeks once we
have managed to make an
overall estimate of the damages deriving
from the flood, we will also make a request
for the activation of the
solidarity fund which, as you know, is a fund
set up precisely for the disasters of
natural calamities, unfortunately at the bottom of
which L  'Italy has already had to log in
other times
but I think it was important that true
president Borderline
also see the extent of the problem with his own eyes and
let's also say the multifaceted problems
we are dealing with because
we obviously need to pay close
attention  on this region
also in relation to programs of
various kinds and to other funds from the
cohesion funds onwards but I think for
example the agricultural theme This is
a company a highly
agricultural region obviously there is a need for
attention for companies that are
particularly in  difficulty
starsment of the Damages and afterwards
solitarity found of Fortune We Were Ask
Force precisely many times and the Past
part It's Great that present progressive
and Kick the real life di Exchange of
the devastation
and many problem state We will have to
face to the Stranger Things  Attention
specialone Comes to Plans to other
founds will be al located I'm thinking of The
origin Fun Sport
citizens
of this region will travel to Cesena
Unfortunately we have the Council of
Ministers so she
will be accompanied as
regards the government to President
Filippo but obviously President
Bonacini is there readings thank you for your
presence for your availability for
your attention we are  working well
very well in these hours and I just want to say
this to President
Borderline when I was
here last Sunday the thing
that struck me the most Besides
obviously the size of the
devastation was the reaction of the
people
here you will find a very  proud
that he has already rolled up his sleeve that he is
already at work rebuilding and is already
rebuilding and has not given up and has
not given up and this, as I have
already said on another occasion, puts
all of us before the responsibility
of  doing our best to be
sick with height
[Music]
Firstly I would like to thank you for
the opportunity you have given me to
be here and for hosting me
flying over the affected areas I must say it
has been very helpful to me it is
truly heart breaking  distressing
to see these deep scars but
above all
entire territories underground the
floods the mud the landslides But
I repeat it was very useful to
realize not only the extent
of the devastation but also the many
problems that will have to be faced
a bit of
Chinese facets
I spoke  with President Bonaccini
who really told me the story
of this region it is a
very prosperous region from an
economic point of view that can boast a
long history a legacy of wealth and
therefore even more painful to see the
devastation that has affected this
region
so here I am  to send a
very clear message that Europe is with
you
ce
Andrew People Change
your
life
Amazing Sea Watch solidarity
I must say that I was also very
impressed by the solidarity that I was
able to see the
civil protection mechanism was mentioned which is
been activated nine Member States have
already given their willingness to offer
support pumps have been made
available from Slovenia
Slovakia other countries there are more than
100 volunteers from these
countries so it is really the best example
of European Union solidarity  and I
was very impressed to also see
hundreds of other Mud Angels volunteers
who are making a contribution
so the solidarity that really
touches me
I have a lot of faith that we can work
together Very well with this
gradual approach obviously now we are making
a contribution in a time of emergency
but clearly we have already talked about the
Solidarity Fund
having experienced first-hand the devastation
that has hit this region in
particular as regards the
Agriculture sector so I
also mention the emergency fund for
agriculture and then the
Solidarity Fund obviously it will be necessary
carry out a damage assessment
Unfortunately this region already has
experience in this sense having been
hit by a terrible earthquake 10-11
years ago and then I would also like to mention the
cohesion funds especially for
preventive purposes within the next
generation in you are allocated six
billions of euros precisely for the
prevention of events like
this of floods of earthquakes for
the consolidation of the Infrastructures
therefore we will adopt a gradual approach
and work well together
in these very difficult days We have
followed let's
say the presence of the president
wonderline in the present melons
certainly for the population
of  It was taken very very important for
our region so I wanted to ask
President Borderline in short, given
that she also mentioned the
2012 earthquake where you can obviously there was
also a very complex situation there
if this Solidarity Fund, precisely
as she has already anticipated, can
be activated  Also on this
occasion and if you already have an idea This is
even a little large the extent of the damages of
how many resources Europe could
could give us could how could it
help
[Music]
absolutely the main source of
these funds will be the Fund of
Solidarity, you are right It is urgent to
ensure that the resources of this fund are put in place
In any case this is how it works
a small pre-payment
of a standard size is allocated For each event,
after the
damage assessment we will have a clearer idea of
how many resources  can be allocated
and this will happen in the next three months in
any case we will collaborate closely
with the President of the Region from
whom I received a letter and therefore
we will absolutely be able to give you
a clearer idea in the future
look on the subject of the commissioner I am
frankly  very impressed by the fact that
this is obnoxious that you are interested
while the
funerals of the people we are
rebuilding are still being celebrated to do
our best and find the
resources when we get to
Reconstruction time we will deal with the
Reconstruction Commissioner  Let's say
that today my main problem
is not who spends the money and that finding it
[Music]
Oh well, it also applies to
center-right governors, it seems to me that
you too have raised very well
constructions instruction
[Music]
of the need to act immediately she
came here  eating twice so
in short he saw the situation it was seen
today there are also problems in
the Apennines landslides and above all there
are municipalities we have dealt with them a bit
these days even very small
blocks that find it difficult to reconstruct
the photos of the streets  so I wanted to understand
if in addition to the Decree to oblige me that it
has already arrived If there is an estimate
In short, other things other answers
especially for these
emergency situations In short, which require immediate
intervention
I think the government has given a
signal, let's say of a very strong commitment
significant I don't know how many other times it
has happened that in
48 hours 72 hours if we have 2
billion and 200 million euros to
deal with emergencies in those two
billion 200 million there is also an
allocation of 200 million euros for
the fund for  'emergency which is dedicated
to Emilia Romagna which we believe makes it
useful to deal with the
situations that have been most
compromised but we have not seen well
Now of the helicopter what we say the
territories that face each other are
different After which we
concentrated above all on the  emergency the
safety especially of the
productive area but also of the
didactic nativity to the agricultural tourist companies
In short, we have given a
first signal they are very important
clearly we do not believe that this is
a sufficient signal to follow to solve
the problem there is a second phase which
concerns  let's say everything in the meantime I repeat an
Assessment a precise definition
of the state of things and therefore also of the
damages we have which will then
always allow with the help of all
the board to be worked on
this very well and the relationship for
example with the commission according to  me is
very important in this phase and which
will clearly serve to draw out the
other
significant resources that I imagine
will be needed to return to
normal here and we will do as we have
demonstrated At the beginning our boat
you know I have to translate I'm sorry
what are you talking about Emergency and the
Productions
[  Music]
Thanks for this
behavior
[Music]